Transcription: Melissa Munns
Relecteur: eric vautier
135 heures est le nombre d’heures passées
en moyenne par chacun d’entre nous,
tous les ans,
coincé dans les embouteillages.
Le problème de congestion et de pollution
dans les centres urbains
est donc un problème majeur et croissant.
Il existe pourtant
dans la plupart des grandes villes
une autoroute déserte et inexploitée.
Cette autoroute, ce sont les voies d’eau :
les lacs, les fleuves, les zones côtières,
Autrefois au centre
de la mobilité urbaine,
ces voies d’eau ont été délaissées
faute de solutions de mobilité navale
adaptées aussi bien aux enjeux
environnementaux d’aujourd’hui
qu’aux enjeux en termes
de rapidité et de performance.
La conception navale est historiquement
un secteur peu innovant
et la plupart des navettes à passagers
que nous voyons en service,
ont été conçues
il y a plusieurs dizaines d’années.
Il y a un peu plus d’un an,
je me suis lancé le défi
de changer la donne.
Pour y arriver, je me suis associé
avec deux personnes clés
pour le succès de ce projet.
Corentin Bigot, architecte naval de renom
et Clément Rousset,
ingénieur naval talentueux.
Le constat posé,
couplé à une forte envie d’innover,
nous avons décidé de réunir
nos 30 années d’expérience cumulées
en hydrodynamique, architecture navale
et développement commercial
pour concevoir
la mobilité navale de demain.
Cette nouvelle solution de mobilité
permettra non seulement
de décongestionner les centres urbains,
mais également de réduire
de façon significative
l’impact environnemental de la mobilité.
Je suis Tanguy Goetz,
le CEO et cofondateur de Net Tech.
Nous avons pour objet
la conception de navires de transport
de passagers et de marchandises,
zéro émission,
performants et intelligents.
Nos navires sont des catamarans à
propulsion hydrogène de 12 à 24 mètres
pouvant accueillir jusqu’à 150 passagers
ou une vingtaine
de tonnes de marchandises.
De la navette fluviale
à la navette maritime,
du transport de passagers
au transport de marchandises,
nous abordons
une stratégie produit innovante
reposant sur un châssis à plateforme
commune à différents usages.
Imaginez alors un trajet
entre Cannes et Monaco, par exemple,
sans bruit, sans odeurs, sans vibrations,
pour ainsi dire,
sans aucune nuisance pour le passager,
mais surtout sans aucune nuisance
pour l’environnement opérationnel.
Cela semble être un rêve lointain,
mais grâce aux technologies qu’on
développe, nous allons le rendre possible.
Nos technologies permettent
effectivement d’utiliser l’hydrogène vert
comme vecteur énergétique.
L’hydrogène vert est produit
à partir d’énergies renouvelables,
il est donc inépuisable et propre.
Intégrer un système
de propulsion hydrogène
représente néanmoins
un défi technologique majeur :
à puissance égale,
un système à propulsion hydrogène,
c’est 3 à 4 fois plus lourd
qu’un système à propulsion diesel.
Or, ajouter une masse supplémentaire
sur un navire
induit une consommation énergétique
plus importante
et donc une dégradation
des performances opérationnelles
en termes de vitesse et d’autonomie.
Cette dégradation n’est pas acceptable
pour les exploitants qui sont prêts
à s’engager dans la transition écologique
vers le navire zéro émission.
Ils sont d’ailleurs
fortement incités à le faire,
mais ils ne souhaitent pas pour autant
chambouler leur modèle économique
et cela notamment en termes de nombre
de passagers transportés tous les jours.
Nos briques technologiques apportent donc
une réponse adaptée
à ce défi technologique
en réduisant les besoins
énergétiques des navires.
Pour cela, nous travaillons sur deux axes.
Tout d’abord, réduire
la traînée hydrodynamique,
donc réduire la résistance à l’avancement
et ensuite augmenter
l’efficacité énergétique des navires.
Nos innovations permettent d’avoir
des gains de l’ordre de 50%
de consommation énergétique en moins.
Cela permet ainsi à nos navires
d’égaler, voire de dépasser,
les performances opérationnelles
des navires diesel actuels.
Notre approche et nos résultats
ont déjà séduit
plus d’une trentaine d’exploitants
de navires de passagers
avec lesquels nous sommes en discussion
technico-commerciale avancée,
sur la façade atlantique
et sur la façade méditerranéenne.
Cela notamment dans le cadre des Jeux
Olympiques et paralympiques 2024,
puisque nous avons récemment été
lauréat d’un appel à innovations
piloté par France Mobilités
pour le déploiement de nos navires
sur la Seine à Paris
et à Marseille,
qui accueillera les épreuves de voile.
Je vous laisse maintenant
avec une image en tête.
Celle de vous,
repartant du Palais des festivals
au volant de votre véhicule,
coincé dans les embouteillages,
dans les odeurs de pots d’échappement,
regardant par la fenêtre
et voyant la mer complètement vide
de navires de transport de passagers,
zéro émission,
performants et intelligents.
Ensemble, nous pouvons agir
pour naviguer vers un monde
plus respectueux de l’environnement,
vers un monde maritime plus bleu.
Merci à tous pour votre attention
et à très vite.
(Applaudissements)